foreign
what's up Terry
hi Dr John thanks for taking my call of
course thank you how are you
I'm great how are you I'm just having a
blast
having a blast what's your life right
yeah exactly it's the it's that YouTuber
life it's that podcaster that's right
all right so what's up
so um I'm calling because I would like
to
get a little insight um how can I help
my husband navigate away from the life
he used to have and the life he wanted
and the life he's living and the feeling
or need that he needs to lie about
things in his past and accept who he is
today
well there's a lot there unpack that for
me yeah
yeah okay do you hear how much
responsibility you've taken on yourself
you can't possibly fix
I know
um I just
I just guide him though I know you love
him
absolutely I don't even know where we're
going but just as you answered that
question
it's a lot
or it's not a lot it's it's an
impossible task so I don't even know
what you're about to ask me
um and we'll get there
um
but do me a favor as you're telling me
this okay
will you uh take a huge deep breath
and hold it for a sec
and then let it out and I want you to
drop your shoulders I want you to
intentionally pull them down like as low
as you can get them away from your ears
okay
all right all right you're carrying a
lot
that's helpful thank you yeah now let's
talk about it
okay
all right now we're going all right so
what's up
so I've done with my husband 12 years
um he's an amazing man I love him
endlessly
um were probably like if I know there's
no I don't believe in soul mates but
we're so greatly matched that I just I
want to help him every step of the way
but in the 12 years
um I do I've obviously learned a lot
about him so he's he's this big guy he
was the football star you know um
his A-game in high school the only
problem is he had a learning reading and
writing disability and he was classified
never able to have a full-time job from
his school and he always wanted to be a
marine and he wanted to make his father
proud but what his learning disability
disability he couldn't pass the ASVAB
testing to do that
and so he kind of just kind of skidded
through life and he had kids he had his
first son before he graduated high
school and so he had to go into the
working field and
so he's he's never been able to really
grieve I guess the life that he wanted
and
um
he feels like he's still trying to prove
that he was good enough and so when we
met
I had he had told me he had he was a
former Marine and things like that and
there's other various
um
non-truths that he's told me and I've
learned throughout our marriage and it
almost broke our marriage but I also
think he may also be on the Spectrum but
he's never I don't know that he's ever
been tested for that and so I just want
to help him
to move past that and I know that when
he was a kid he had a hard life and I
lying was part of his his life because
he had such a hard upbringing and
um he's got some traumas that he's never
actually
um work through either so I'm just
curious how like how I can help him move
through that
what just came to my mind is gonna sound
really harsh okay
can I can I just let it all out with you
I'm gonna do this but um we're on the
same team right
yes okay
oh man the greatest gift you could give
him
would be to stop using him
because you're getting something from
all of this
all right and whether it's caretaking
or whether it's
you get to really make somebody who has
never been loved feel loved and that
feels good
um
you're continuing to the way you even
phrase it you started the call by saying
how much you loved him and how great and
how wonderful he is he just has some
non-truths
another way to say that he's been lying
to you for the entirety of your marriage
not about trivial things about huge
things you married her you married a
veteran
yeah I thought I did yeah it wasn't a
veteran I thought I married someone I'd
never been married before he had been
married
that's right
yeah these are amazing
and I know you can say the fact that you
can say to your knowledge he's never
been tested y'all been married for 12
years
oh yeah
you know what I mean
yeah it's so completely the hard thing
is you're getting something out of this
Arrangement what is it
I wish I knew are you getting security
out of it are you getting uh love I know
that's unconditional what are you
getting
I know he loves me unconditioning it
unconditionally as well because I mean
our marriage almost fell apart because I
had to step away for a little while
because when my dad died it woke me up
to some things and so I had to step away
for six months and through the six
months he was still
very you know text me every day call me
every day need to know how I was doing
he was worried about me and my
well-being what were you what woke you
up when your dad passed
um
when I found out that my husband hadn't
served in the Marine Corps it was the
only thing I ever lied to my father
about and when my dad
thought he had hurt my mother had
corrected my dad on well he never served
so my dad called me and said somebody in
the family is lying about him and I love
this man he's my son now and so I
couldn't bring myself to tell my dad the
truth and so
it's the only thing that ever lied to my
father about so
I had to step away and really think
about things and where I wanted what I
wanted
um out of this relationship and him so
that's what
I had I felt I had to do so I stepped
away for a little bit so and you it was
it was hard what brought you back a
really good place now I do try to
correct him on things
um
he's not being truth like and he's not
doing it um it's not I don't feel as
malicious intent I just feel that he has
shame for his past Hey listen listen
listen listen listen
you are not being honest with yourself
our past are real
and they cause long-term behavioral
shifts
there's a biochemical process there
there is a behavioral process there's a
habituation process there there's all
these different reasons
until I started listening to your show
and I'm I have a very high Asus score
myself and yeah that's what I'm getting
at
somewhere along the way you came to
believe that this is what you were worth
and you're not
and if your husband's got special needs
and he's got learning disabilities
um that prohibit him from telling the
truth
that prohibit him from seeing reality as
it is
there's much bigger issues going on here
but your continual
um you continue to
brush very hurtful Behavior under a rug
because of things that happened to him a
long time ago he's a grown adult with
kids and a wife of over a decade two
wives
he's got to grow up
and he's got to act like an adult
and he's got to get the healing that he
needs to get done and he's got to get
the resources that he needs to overcome
his
um learning disabilities and his
learning challenges or as they call him
now learning exceptionalities
and there's too many resources out there
but I don't know any outside of some
outside of the bell curve psychiatric
disorders
we're just lying about big huge Rock
things
is something that somebody can't control
and more importantly
because he's not on the phone with me
right now
yeah you
carry your worth being married to
somebody who's going to lie to you about
everything
and you're worth it's deeper than that
though because you can't put both feet
on the ground because you don't know
where the where the ground is solid
mm-hmm
and lying's one part of it what else is
there
are you safe I
absolutely um he's I've never felt safer
with anybody
um he is so protective over myself and
our daughter okay
um he he's
I know it sounds oxymoronic with what
you just said but he was very caring
when it comes to me and my child as far
as whether we're loved and we're safe
um
but I just I want to help him kind of
see recognize what he's doing and
because I don't sometimes I don't think
he recognizes it
um
if if what you're asking me is how can
you help him recognize it as you sit
down and you say when you lie I don't
feel safe and I don't feel loved
okay
and if you continue to lie and make me
feel unsafe and unloved I'm gonna decide
to not be in this relationship anymore
because you are telling me
that
um your feeling of inadequacy is more
important than me being loved and safe
okay your need to make up stories about
your past and your present and your
future
so that you don't have to face reality
makes me feel untethered and unsafe and
it makes me really feel worried about
our daughter
okay
and then he gets to be an adult and make
some really hard choices is he going to
get the mental health care that he needs
is he going to get the does he have a
job is he working
absolutely he's actually a a foreman for
um our local government Road great
things
um he does one he's an amazing worker he
he works night and day you know to
provide for us and everything awesome um
he's one of those big you know like how
you always talk about your big Texas guy
and big strong men don't have feelings
it's definitely
um yeah so at some point and maybe it's
you decide to go to a a a counselor
okay a therapist
um have you been have you seen somebody
um I'm looking into it I'm trying to
find someone in my local area what is
your uh Aces score
I
thought
pretty traumatic childhood myself okay
um will you stop looking into it and
just make a call
yeah
you promise
I do promise I've already done it taken
the steps for my daughter to have that
okay
you are taking care of everybody in your
life except for Terry
which is a really common thing for
somebody who had to survive their entire
life
uh-huh
true
yes okay I want you to love Terry as
much as you love this husband of yours
I want you to love Terry as much as you
love your daughter
because somewhere along the way some
things happen to you this should not
have happened and
that communicated stories to you of what
your value was
and it was less than everybody else is
that right okay yeah it's not true
thank you
you don't believe me though and I I'm
okay with that you you will believe me
over time if you'll go talk to somebody
okay yeah I did it when I
went on me in it um
but uh you know Financial things and
stuff like that can always continue to
do it no I know I know it's it's it's
incredibly expensive and it's cost
prohibitive and it's a National Disgrace
in some some cases yeah
but it is what it is that's where we're
at okay
um right now this is more important I
mean you've read the data on that stuff
I've uh
I mean the likelihood that your life is
going to be way more challenging and way
shorter because of those experiences
because your body's still trying to
protect you
um I don't want that for you I want that
for your little girl I want that for
your husband I want y'all to have peace
I do too I know you do it'd be amazing I
know you do what's the one thing keeping
you from taking that step
foreign
I know his sister had offered to
pay us or pay for us to do um couples
therapy and you know he didn't want
anything to do with that he wanted to
work on it on her own and I think I'm
making some Headway with him but not
I'm not quite there yet because I I feel
that we all need it
so
there's gonna come a moment when you
have to say this is the way this is
going to be
yeah
okay
and my hope is on the other side of you
meeting with a good trauma counselor and
working through some of this
awful stuff that happened to you
and in addition to the awful stuff that
happened to you just parents dropping
their kid off at a counselor's office
once a week
um
and not providing a healing environment
at home isn't helpful either okay
okay you've been through a lot that
little body of your has been through a
lot
it has yeah and that little teenager
that little girl that's been protecting
you for a long time she's really
freaking tired right now
because she's you but you haven't
connected the dots yet and that's what
trauma does it disconnects us from
everything
that little girl is something special
and
so has grown up Terry
and the only person that can't see that
is Terry
do you ever feel like if you started
crying you would never be able to stop
yep yes
here's the thing and cows is a gross and
a word but in Council we call it leakage
you can deal with it and let it out or
it will find its way out and it usually
finds its way out in a really
inopportune times
okay
yeah
to answer your original question you
can't
there's nothing you're not doing
your husband isn't lying to you for
anything that you've done great
that's on him
those are choices he's making
and I've got my own stuff in my past
that I will never speak about publicly
ever I just won't and what I'll tell you
is
all of us have choices to make when
we're grown-ups right yep
and at some point he needs to choose to
quit lying to the single most important
person in his life
that's a choice he's going to make it's
not because of his childhood it's
because of his adult choices and you
can't fix that or heal that or you're
not doing anything wrong okay okay my
hope is on the back end of this you're
going to listen Back and You're Going to
Hear I mean you were you were trauma
101.
everybody who's hurting in your life is
your fault your kids are struggling
because of stuff you're not doing right
what do you need to be doing to help
your husband not fill in the blank lie
to you be disrespectful to you not pay
pay for stuff like you know I mean like
all we keep it on a list yeah at you at
the epicenter because everything's your
fault and it's not it's not
okay
will you say the words out loud I'm
worth being well
I am worth being well and I'm gonna make
a call
I'm gonna make a call and then I'm gonna
show up
I will show up awesome will you keep me
in the loop on how they go yes okay make
no bones about it Terry it's gonna be
hell going forward me hard
okay it's gonna be hard
if you think of it like this when you
have surgery they actually take a knife
and they cut you open
to get out whatever's wrong or to fix
the bone that's broken or to get out the
tumor or whatever they actually hurt you
more during surgery it hurts and you
bleed and it's tough and then they take
care of you and they close up the wound
and then you start a healing process and
then you go to rehab and then all of a
sudden you wake up and you are stronger
than you ever imagined
and it's time
I'm sorry that somebody hurt you I'm
sorry that somebody continues to hurt
you and calls it love
but you're worth being well